good evening and welcome to planning
committee of straford on a district
council my name is councelor Lewis Adam
I'm your chairman for this evening some
housekeeping to begin with um there's no
fire alarm planned so if it does go off
please make an orderly exit and the
muster point is the car park uh by the
pub across the road uh please make sure
your phones are
off or at least in silent mode so they
don't disturb the flow of the meeting uh
this is a meeting in public not a public
meeting and so only those registered to
speak are permitted to do so um I'll
call the relevant people forward and
give further instructions at the uh
appropriate time um the meeting will be
recorded and live streamed on our
website okay uh I'll now introduce our
top table from democratic Services we've
got Olivia Quinn our list this evening
is Amy Shipley our planning manager is
Alice cosnet and our planning officers
are Stuart FY and Sarah FL and Alice I
believe you got a statement prepared
thank you chairman my role is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision
taking thank you very much okay we now
move on to the agenda item one is
apologies for absence chair we have
apologies from councelor padam lovely
thank you very much
uh item two disclosures of interest do
we have any disclosures ccor
Harvey chair I did a rcky on both
sides thank you very much councelor
Perry thank you and good evening
chairman I'm the ward member for the uh
agenda item number five old pastures
farm so we'll be sitting down from the
committee and I have registered to speak
thank you very much councelor Keeley
thanks chair yes I'm declaring an
interest because uh this is in respect
of agenda item for the veteranary
investigation Center at lington because
I was a parish counselor for nearly
three years and leading the working
group on this particular site I've got a
great depth of knowledge about it I be
stepping away when you're discussing
that item totally good thank you um also
um make a declaration that we were
contacted I believe on item uh five live
by um concerned party I think that went
to all committee members so that would
just be a blanket dispensation any
further
disclosures no okay very good in which
case we now move on to item three
minutes uh we've got minutes from the
meeting held on the 20th of December uh
they should have been circulated any
changes for
members no in which case we're agreed on
those Char good I'll sign those in due
course right we can now move on then to
to item four which is the first
application application
n/r vety investigation Center lington
Road lington now as per the re the
update sheet the um officers have
updated their recommendation to one of
deferral um due to additional
information being submitted that they
would like to consider before making a
formal recommendation either which way
um on that basis I'm going to make the
proposal that we defer and seek a
seconder got um just like counselor Eden
in this case anyone else want to
contribute no in which case can I see
all those in favor of deferral
please that's unanimous chair thank you
very much okay so uh committee resolves
then that application
23277 nrm be deferred to a future
committee
date right and as our planning officer
gets situated we now move on to item
five which is
application uh
23799 ful old pastures Farm Stratford
Road Hampton Lucy our presenting officer
is Sarah flaty and once you're ready
feel free to take it
away
thank you chairman this is a full
planning application for an extension to
the pack house and cold storage facility
at Old pest Farm the application site is
Den denoted by the red line on this plan
and is located within an area of open
Countryside a public foot path runs
through through the site and can be seen
here by the green dashed
line the site is also located within the
setting of grade one listed charot Park
and it's also near to Hampton Lucy and
alvon conservation areas so the villages
are denoted on this this uh image and
the site access can be seen here at the
top with the application building seen
here here we see the the proximity of
the site to the sheded ancient Monument
which is located just to the north of
the application building which is also
seen
here this plan shows the existing
building in White and the proposed
extension in Gray the extension will be
located within the existing area of
hardstanding within the Farm
Complex here we see the proposed floor
plans of the extension at the bottom
with the uh extension proposed of the
2020 application which was dismissed
appeal in March 2023 seen at the top
just for comparison
the principal change is this part has
been removed so you can see here which
pulls it back from the sheded ancient
Monument the extension will provide
space for refrigeration packing office
and Welfare
facilities here we see the proposed
elevations of the building the gray
element denotes the existing building
seen here and the white shows the
proposed
extension this image is taken facing
Northeast with the existing back house
seen in the background the extension
will be located on the area of hard
standing seen here in the
foreground here we Face the Southwest
with a pack ha scene on the right and
another agricultural burning scene
behind this vehicle towards the
rear uh finally this image is taken
facing Northeast and shows the end
elevation of the building the extension
will wrap around this elevation and the
area of the shed na Monument can be seen
just in the background the green
here chairman the appeal dismissed in
March 2023 for a similar extension to
the pack house is a material
consideration in the termination of this
application the inspector for this
appeal only found harm to the sheded
ancient monument and this matter has now
been addressed as such officers find the
principal development to be acceptable
with no harm found to the setting of The
Heritage assets including the sheded
ancient Monument no harm from the scale
or design of the extension identified
the recommendation is therefore to Grant
Subject to a response of no objection
from the llfa and subject to the
conditions and notes as detailed on page
25 of the agenda gend and the updates in
the update sheet thank
you thank you very much all right uh
members I will alert you to the update
sheet which um has uh something on both
sides just make sure you do uh consider
that um we now move on to our
first
Thomas from Hampton Lucy Parish
Council good evening counselor um so
once you're seated the um it's the
button on the right hand side to turn
the microphone on uh you have a total of
three minutes um to speak I'm happy to
give you a 30 second warning before your
time's
up it doesn't appear so I'm happy
just okay I'll just check with Democrat
services
yes so I believe those were the ones
that were circulated to the members
which are disclosures made for so
members have had opportunity to see them
just so you know okay um so yeah like I
said it's button on the right hand side
to um make the microphone live that's it
you have three minutes I'll give you a
30 second warning and when you're ready
take it away right thank you um these
are comments made on behalf of Hampton
Lucy parish council with regard to the
application for the extension to the
Packa
at Old pastur form now in the statement
the app applicant confirms the
development is for the central location
for crops being refrigerated processed
packed and distributed it does not limit
this to what is grown on the side it
does not limit operational hours it will
pack and distribute an additional 400
pallets of crops which must necessarily
be delivered from other Farms as farming
methods on the site have not really
changed
uh since 2012 this is there for a B2 and
B8 use and not ancillary forming on the
side it is for industrial packing and
distribution we think it is already
beginning to happen produce from the
applicants of farms has seen been
delivered through the site through the
village every day during the growing
season and is also being imported from
elsewhere out of season on the 13th of
January a refrigerated articulated lry
with a Spanish number plate was seen
driving through Hampton Lucy to the site
over the fragile listed um Bridge uh
which is evidence we think that produce
from abroad is being processed there
other similar um trucks have been cited
this week the highway
infrastructure uh is already unsuitable
to support support
hgvs Hatton Bank Lane and Stratford Road
are undesignated narrow and damaged at
their edges this development would
Dangerously exacerbate the problem there
have been three and there's one there's
a photograph to spot that there have
been three accidents within the last two
months at the sharp end at Stratford
Road after H H Bank Lane by Vehicles
avoiding others and one of these
involved um a vehicle from the
side um again I think we have
photographs shown the aftermath of these
extensive flooding has occurred
around 19 2020 and and earlier this
month we've provided drone pictures for
this the runoff from an additional
1,833 square meter building which is
equivalent to the size of seven tennis
courts um 8.3 M high will intensify the
flooding WCC flood and risk management
have objected to this application in
August and November
2023 and again uh on the 17th of January
this year with these objections and
those of other statutary consult
consules and other valid grounds we
believe this application should be
refused thank you very much just within
your time members do we have any
questions for our Parish
Council councilor
pton thank you chair good evening
um what are the and I will clarify this
but what's your understanding of the
operating hours currently you you've
mentioned a 247 operation what what do
we currently
have um I'm I'm not sure I mean there
are I mean I think it may vary with
season certainly in the summer there are
trucks um
um uh tractors and trailers going
through the Village from very early to
quite late but not so much in the winter
a second question uh thank you again
this may not be something you can
confirm but you mentioned in your
presentation uh the question of bringing
produce from offsite rather than produce
that's grown onsite yeah so have you any
definitive uh evidence to support that
contention um as I say we have sort of
recently seen Spanish trucks um
refrigerated trucks coming through the
village and going to the site now at the
moment there is virtually no production
on site so um we um think that they
can't be to take things away so um we we
presume this is to
deliver okay Council keithy next yeah
thanks chair um thank you councelor
Thomas um it was really a followup to
councilor pemberton's question I was
interested in the um the the traffic
flows to and from the the uh the farm um
and uh you've described that there was
no produce on the farm at the moment and
trucks are coming
in do the when there is produce coming
off the farm do the trucks still use the
same routing um the trucks are supposed
to use a routing on the Stratford Road
and then up um to the road by dobbies
and onto the main road right um they
don't always stick to this um some come
up through Hatton bank I seeing two
large hgvs come up that way in the last
me two weeks okay but they they
gradually got they go they're not
supposed to go through the village
because of the the Iron Bridge which has
a 7.5 ton uh limit understand that thank
you we are
seeing vehicles from other countries
going over the bridge I assume that
they're not
they don't pick up the the signs thank
you thank you um councelor Harvey
next thank you chairman councelor Thomas
um help me out if you can um on the
question of flooding and the the risk of
flooding um we're told in our papers
that the farm is uh in flood zone
one
and the site is already concreted over
its concrete
platform and the propos is to put a bill
building on
it I'm struggling to understand how
putting a a roof over a concrete
platform so to speak has any significant
makes any significant difference to the
flooding risk could could you expand on
that well obviously we're guided um to a
large extent by the flood risk
management um assessment here where um
they have um the mitigation that's being
put in for this um is considered not
sufficient at the moment so there was a
um a report on the 17th of January um
which uh with WCC uh mind standing
objected to the current plan based on
that I'm not a I'm obviously not a um a
water engineer so we have something in
common so we have to be guided by these
technical assessments I think
thank you any further questions for our
Parish Council
Representative no in which case thank
you very much for your
contribution okay next speaker will be
Mr Martin Andrews from Alston villagers
Association good evening Mr
Andrews uh so similarly you have three
minutes I'm happy to give you a 30
second warning um when your time's
almost up uh it's the button on the
right hand side to uh turn the
microphone on and uh once you're ready
feel free to take it away great
thank you very much chairman uh yes I'm
speaking you today as an alviston
resident but also on behalf of the
aliston village Association to object
against the proposal uh based on three
concerns the first one is
industrialization of the rural site the
second is re uh increase of flood risk
and also the risk of pollution from
various sources which I'll go into so
starting with industrialization you've
heard some of this already the planning
and design access statement states that
Refrigeration packaging and dis patch
from one Central facility will increase
volumes by an additional 400 pallets per
of product per week just to put that
into context that's 40 7 1/2 ton
truckloads or roughly eight a day or 18
articulated L 44 ton trucks about three
a day and this seems very in congruous
with the claim of a reduction in local
traffic uh no mention at all is made of
the uh imported products coming on site
which is happening today I live opposite
the site and I seen three continental
Livery trucks uh this week uh two of
them I saw at 8:15 on Tuesday morning
and this is a time of year when there
are no products growing there at all um
secondly increased flood risk uh the
area between alvaston charart and
Hampton Lucy I'm sure as you know uh is
uh a natural flood plane it acts to
store water in times of river flooding
and uh it's at least an annual
occurrence and has flooded many many
times over the years now the incremental
developments on the site substantially
decrease the amount of permeable area
where flood water can drain away uh so
things like the concreting of area for
buildings uh storage process work or
accommodation Caravan hardstanding the
several large reservoirs Lorry parking
loading Bays all of this eats into the
the flood plane um now this puts a lot
more pressure on the surface water
drainage and I think as the previous
speaker mentioned there was an objection
a third objection from the llfa uh
because of the inadequacy of the
drainage or at least the the system
thirdly pollution risk now we know that
salad crops understandably require
washing to remove pesticides bacteria
and soil and that requires sub
substantial amounts of possible water to
be used and it's well documented that
the food industry uses chlorine based
disinfectants in order to do wash the
Machinery as well as the produce and uh
again there's no mention of this in the
uh application in terms of what
chemicals are used how will wash water
be disposed of um environmental health
also had initially objected to the on
the basis of the 24-hour day uh working
and this was in relation to noise um on
site now as a local resident uh facing
the site I can tell you I can hear noise
already um and a noise of sight
assessment was not undertaken at the
time due to covid and it hasn't been
since then either uh lastly light
pollution it's already an issue there is
a glaring SPL uh so on the basis of
those real three points of
industrialization risk of flooding and
pollution risk are the basis of the
objection thank you thank you very much
members do we have any questions for our
uh speaker c h serin thank you chair
good evening um this proposed building
is is it going on existing concrete slab
or is it off the existing my
understanding is it's going on an
existing concrete slab yeah yeah okay
thank you thank you any further
questions no in which case thank you may
I add a few context because I'm afraid
unless we've got a question from
thinking there was a few unanswered
questions from the last speaker I might
be able to shed some light on that if it
helps but hours of work I'm happy to
have members ask you additional
questions but um I'm afraid I can't
invite those unsolicited if you
understand my meaning councelor pton
thank okay um I was interested to
understand the current hours of
operation yeah well yes and I will
clarify this with the agent but what is
your understanding of the current hours
of operation and days of operation for
that matter so basically it's seven days
a week uh during the Harvest time during
the growing season um there are workers
in the fields from literally Dawn so
that's usually about sixish onwards and
it can be late into the evening into
dusk as well um in terms of this time of
year uh I would say the vehicles start
moving before
daylight uh and they stop I would say uh
probably very late afternoon 56 the
notable thing is that the light is on
all night there's a spotlight on all
night so it's difficult to know whether
there's activity going on in addition to
that they're also uh during the
harvesting and planting periods you've
got people living on site in the
accommodation who have the occasional
party that I can hear quite late into
the night I think I've got the answer to
my question thank you thank you coun
Harvey can I sort sort of repeat my
question about um flooding yes if the if
the site is in flood zone one I it's got
the lowest risk of flooding if the
concrete apron upon which the building
the new building is is already there in
place if there's no additional
concreting going to take place that's a
question is there can you explain to me
how the flood risk from runoff rain
rainwater is
increased yeah there's um there's an
interesting comment in the objection
from the llfa on that was submitted on
the 17th of January I'll read it out to
you for clarity uh it states that whilst
the llf they acknowledge that the
application site is not within a surface
water or fluvial flood zone according to
the National mapping the site outfall is
adjacent to the adjacent water course is
within flood zones 3 associated with the
river aen uh the LFA would therefore
recommend a sensitivity test is
undertaken on the network modeling now I
think if you read the rest of the
objection and again I'm know flood
engineer um it suggests that what the uh
flood risk management engine enger is
challenging here is the adequacy of the
whole drainage system so it's not just
uh you know some runoff off a roof
that's already in flood zone one it's
the whole area around it and again
because I'm have the privilege of living
opposite uh side of the river whenever
the river floods and whenever the area
floods I get a bird's eye view from my
bedroom window of of exactly where it
goes and I can tell you it it's
extensive all around that area so I
think the concern is not so much the
individual building but actually its
impact and Associated impact on the
whole area and I think as more of these
developments occur so if it's a a
building here a shed there a hard
standing there a lorry Park here it's
just the cumulative impact of that onto
the area which is my understanding of
the the requirements does that answer
your
question it gives me more information
okay thank you uh any further questions
no I believe that's everything thank you
very much for your contribution
okay we'll now move on to our next
speaker who is Laurel Lee
Davies agent for the applicants good
evening even uh so you've got six
minutes um I'm happy again to give you a
30 second warning before your time's up
and uh yeah the microphone's on so when
you're ready take it away
lovely thank you chair and good evening
members I am here today speaking on
behalf of the applicant Val Fresco the
applicant proposals seek to to extend
the existing building to allow for
harvested crops to be refrigerated
processed packaged and dispatched from
one Central facility the proposals
represent an appropriate and essential
Agricultural Development which will
deliver significant long-term economic
and environmental benefits such as a
significant reduction in CO2 emissions
given the applicants currently have to
make a 50- mile round trip to
ofam increase output and improved
quality of produce for consumers inward
investment in food technology and the
creation of local
jobs it's important to understand the
planning inspectorate found the original
application to be sound subject to
further investigation of the impact of
the proposals on the adjacent scheduled
ancient Monument the appeal was
dismissed solely on this point all of
matters such as the principle of
development the effect of the propos
upon the character and appearance of the
area highway safety noise pollution and
biodiversity have already been
considered
acceptor accordingly the applicant
revised the plans and undertook
pre-application discussions with
historic England where by follow
following a site visit it became evident
that the proposals do not extend beyond
existing hard services and therefore
scheduled Monument consent is not
required nor any further archaeological
investigations necessary as a result
historic England no longer object to
this
development the appeal decision is a
significant material consideration in
the determin of this application and so
it is imperative that a decision is made
in line with the inspector's assessment
if counselors seek to overturn the
officer's recommendation please be
mindful the applicant will appeal the
decision and there will be a great risk
of cost being awarded against the
council as the applicant has applied for
a grant from defra it is vital that this
application progress positively without
any further delays in order for the
funding to be successful planning perion
must be in place by the end of January
members are therefore respectfully
requested to uphold the officer's
recommendation of approval thank
you thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for R uh yes Council p
thank you chair uh before asking my
question I'm going to make an
observation with respect I all I was
going to say chair is that I don't
respond well to threats I am well aware
of the process for planning I am well
aware of the applicants ability to
appeal I don't need to be reminded about
that and I don't imagine any other
member of this it's questions my
question relates to I have two questions
my first question relates to um the
hours of
operation and alongside that what sites
are being serviced currently and what
Serv sites are envisioned to be serviced
in terms of the packing operation so
that's two parts of an operational
question then I have a second question
on
construction okay so um the existing
hours of operation are between 8:00 a.m.
and 600 p.m. um and all of the movements
are not within peak
hours and um and sorry what do you mean
in terms of
other no change to the operational hours
is what you're saying no I don't believe
a condition has beened to restrict that
and that was covered in the transport
statement that's submitted and address
it appeal okay um the second question
relates to what sites are currently
serviced what Farms are currently
serviced by this operation you talk
about centralizing so are there
additional sites that are going to be
serviced by this packing operation No so
at the moment V Fresco have a pack house
in ofam so any of the produce from the
old pastor's Farm has to go to ofam to
be packaged then back to Val Fresco to
be processed so you know we're cutting
out that middle Journey which is 50 mile
round trip a day which takes place
multiple times a day especially in the
summer
periods uh my second question relates to
construction there have been some
comments around the concrete platform
plinth and that the new building will
not result in any greater surface area
that's correct are do you happen to know
whether there will be a need for
deepening of the raft for the
foundations for The Bu in other words I
I imagine this is a it's a car park
which is so deep you've got to you've
got a construct a building and you've
got a additional mass of concrete and
steel to support the weight of the
building I appreciate that may not be
something you can assist with but can if
you can it would help me um it's not I'm
afraid but that could be conditioned
with a construction management plan and
further details could be submitted if
necessary thank you any further
questions councelor keithy next thank
you very much chair um thank you Mr
Davis um for your presentation I was
just interested to know about the def
Grant what what what's the significance
of the defr grant you mentioned that
that there was some sort of time looming
on a defr grant how much is it for and
why is it significant in this
application So Def release um Grant for
funding of agricultural development when
this one meets the definition the
applicant has said um has been um you
know has been able to get the funding
and um it needs to be in place by
January to for that funding to be
delivered are you suggesting then that
that this wouldn't go ahead without this
this funding no no we' just have to
reapply for the grant again and with
time scales it will probably delay it
and it might be next year thank
you thank you uh councilor strander next
uh lovely thank you chair um and thank
you Mr Davies um you presented a great
deal of information thank you um can I
just check one thing um can you just
restate you mentioned the sole reason
the appeal was rejected could you just
repeat that for me please just for
clarity um I'll just read that half of
the paragraph Panner inspectorate found
the original application to be sound
subject to further investigation of the
impact of the proposals on the adjacent
scheduled H monin the was dismissed
solely on this point and that's why we
um reduced the floor plans slightly so
it wasn't on the sched ENT Monument okay
so it was the Sam okay thank you I do
have how many questions can I ask chair
okay so also um can do you have any
comment on the um two observations about
the Continental lores entering the site
no I
don't so that's just a mystery uh it's
you know it's not part of the
application that we're presenting
today okay but you did suggest that it
was all lores within from your company
that will be using the pack house
absolutely that will be but currently
there are other European
companies I don't know I'm afraid okay
that's fine um and then my last question
um relates to um councelor Harvey's
question
about um The increased risk of flooding
so I think we've established that the
conrete pad on which this building will
sit already exists so that surface area
is accounted for but in developing that
will there need to be additional
hardstanding concrete laid for
additional parking additional hgvs
additional housing Etc no there will be
no need for any further hardstanding and
um the drainage measures that we are
proposing and are currently with the
drainage consultant will actually
restrict flows and therefore improve the
drainage situation than currently or is
okay thank you thank you very much cast
Harvey I've got three
questions chairman
um councelor Thomas raised the issue of
B2 and
B8 I presume you think that's irrelevant
could you tell can you tell me why you
think it's irrelevant please I do
because Pack houses and the the um
services that go within pack houses are
deemed Agricultural
Development okay fact um traffic
movements local residents think that
there's going to be an increased number
of traffic
movements your traffic statement says
there're going to be fewer have you got
any data about current levels of traffic
movements and projected levels of
traffic movements with this Packing
House in place uh the data that we have
submitted would be within the transport
statement um which has been consulted on
by the highways and they've ra no
objections and I just have to reiterate
that these transport movements will be
reduced because it's now going to be one
Central facility uh can I just follow up
on that particular question on my
reading of the transport statement there
were no no figures in there of Transport
movements that's why I asked the
question right so have you got any data
on on TR I don't have any this data with
me no so we established there is no data
upon which to to base this assessment of
whether it's increased or decreased is
that correct
that we don't need data for that you
don't need data the the highway
Authority has not needed or requested
further data for this matter okay you
don't need data that's
fine my final question is there's an
accusation that um there'll be an
increased amount of water usage as a
result of having to wash uh salad etc
etc is there any need for any additional
facility
as a result of that that washing
operation as far as treatment of water
is
concerned um I don't believe so I think
everything that is proposed can be
accommodated within this
extension thank you very much any
further questions councelor
passingham C could I ask what sort of
salad vegetables are being grown and
packed on the side
can I ask my applicant he's sitting
here there's lot of question planning
agent point of view I'm happy for a very
very brief answer from the from the
applicant but no no elaboration further
I'm afraid
of that's probably all all the answer we
can we can
get yeah thank you uh I take it that you
question Council passingham any further
questions no in which case thank you
very much for your
contribution okay we now move on then to
our final speaker who is the W member
councelor
Parry yes
certainly yes so good evening councelor
you have five minutes um and I'm very
happy to give you a 30 second warning
thank you chair and good evening nice to
be
back as a former Port portfolio holder
for economic development and very Pro
economic growth in the district provided
this is in the right place and reflects
the right type of activity particularly
in the open
Countryside however what you have in
front of you is not just an extension to
existing pack house and cold storage
facility at Old pastures but the
proposed development of a new industrial
packing operation also handling European
Imports and wide ranging produce from
across the West Midlands it is therefore
not subservient to the existing packing
facility nor designed to reflect the
existing farm buildings and businesses
therefore Contra contravening both cs20
and
cs9 warshire County Council is the lead
local flood Authority is extremely
concerned about the proposed large-scale
development of the site and its impact
on neighboring facilities and
infrastructure which is evidenced by the
horrific flooding that occurred earlier
this month such is their concern that
they submitted another response last
week in respect to this application
recommending refusal which reflects SD's
policy CS4 water environment and flood
risk had John Glenn Denning still been
at WCC highways he too would be
objecting on highways grounds as he
highlighted in a previous application to
extend the pack house and cold storage
facility on this site that the highways
Authority would have concerns regarding
additional floor space for General B2
and B8 uses which would lead to an
increase in trip
generation it's extremely clear that WCC
has not Revisited its previous
consultations in respect to the sites
history and consequently proper due
diligence has not been carried out for
B2 and B8 use in the open
Countryside together with the access
into the site increas in hgv traffic
movements and the road accident reports
there is no way that the proposed new
facility is to be used by only produce
from old pastures form in accordance
with the condition and how can this be
monitored and enforced
the sheer scale of this proposed design
therefore has a significant impact on
the character of the landscape
riverscape and Gateway entrance into the
village as well as the setting of The
Heritage assets which Overlook old
pastures farm and therefore does not
Accord with CS5 cs8 nor the mppf Paris
174 and
202 this is also evidenced by robust
objections from The National Trust
Gardens trust historic England and yes
our very own landscape officer at
SDC granting this application will
result in an unacceptable
industrialization of Hampton Lucy's
beautiful River Valley there is also no
satisfactory evidence to support the
argument that public benefits of the
scheme outweigh the harm caused it would
also have an impact on tourism being on
the more direct route from traford to
chalk cut house and chut Mill put quite
simply this is not an extension of an
existing agricultural business but the
development of a major new commercial
packing plant which must be refused on
the lfa's objection to flooding and on
our own professional landscape officers
objection thank you very much counselor
well within your time members do we have
any questions for our Ward
member
nothing
forthcoming oh councelor Harvey at the
last second um councelor Perry in that
contribution I I don't think I heard
anything about flooding or the risk of
flooding I made reference to the um
local flood um the lead local flood
Authority from
WCC um raising their major concerns
regarding the
flooding the flood risk and and that
they also
um sent in a further objection last week
which follows the extens of flooding the
whole area experienced literally two to
three weeks
ago thank you for reminding
me any further questions for our war
member no in which case thank you very
much for your contribution thank
you right uh we can now move on then to
points of clarification for our officers
do we have any points clarification
councilor
Harvey um could you explain in simple
terms the in planning terms the
difference between um a packing
operation which is an extension to an
agricultural business an existing
agricultural
business and an industrial
development um in terms of the use we're
satisfied that it falls within an
agricultural use it's related to the
agricultural holding and the operation
being undertaken it's an use ancillary
or function and cery to the growing of
crops on the site so that's why we're
satisfied that it's an agricultural use
now you'll note that on
page 25 year of your agenda we've
recommended a condition if minders if
members are minded to grant that it will
be used only as a pack house and cold
storage facility for the storage and
processing of agricultural produce
around rising from old pastures farm and
for no other purposes so if they were to
use it for anything other than that so
say they were to argue well it is
industrial we can use it for any
industrial purpose that's not the case
because it's tied down by that condition
so it's really considering whether you
think the impact of that specific use is
appropriate in that location in terms of
the various impacts that set out in the
report question um the fact that this is
an extension and not a separate building
would would the officer's view be
influenced
by that
distinction I think for me in my
professional opinion in landscape terms
it's going to be better as an extension
generally speaking because you're
consolidating the built form more
tightly together I think because they're
saying that it is an extension to the
existing building I'm um my
understanding is that the operation of
the business will benefit from those
buildings being conjoined so it being an
extension as opposed to a a standalone
building thank you any further points
yes Council
pen thank thank you chair um a number of
questions and one I think may involve
legal advice as well um when we talk
about so the principle of the operation
is
established and our policies seek to
support development and expansion of
businesses can officers give any
guidance to the committee when extension
of a
business turns into something entirely
different so a farm produce a farm
produce shop turns into supplying 60% of
the world's
Tomatoes where do we draw the line what
in in policy terms what guidance is
there between an extension and a natural
growth and what is certainly feared by
the local community um an entirely
different operation which potentially
where it from the ground upwards we
might take a different view of in other
words well there is a question if this
was you know from the ground upwards
would we take a different view so some
help along that that's my first
question um so it's very much a matter
of fact and degree when you're talking
about how buildings are being used in
terms of when it tips from one youth
class to another we we've looked at the
application as submitted and we're
satisfied and it's it's an extension to
existing business and for the reason set
out in the report that it's Justified
obviously if members were to take a
different approach obviously that's
within your gift um obviously we have
previously accepted the principle of
development so that's on the first
question can I just seek a bit more
clarity I think I'm talking about the
scale you know the question of a
business that as I say goes from a you
know a farm shop to supplying the
world's Tomatoes the scale of the change
to what extent does that play into our
assessment it would be every application
on its own Merit so we'd consider what's
before us in this case we're satisfied
that the scale is appropriate to be an
extension right rather than the creation
of a new or different business on the
site um so the second question is um in
other scenarios we look at extensions as
being subservient to the main building
this is anything but subservient to the
main building
so how does that play out and and and to
what it it well it more than doubles the
size of the building and it has a seems
to have an additional story so how is
that how do we how does that play out in
terms of its you know uh the size and
mass of the
building so this is where the previous
appeal decision is quite help well very
helpful so previously with the last
application which was marginally bigger
we refused the application on the impact
on Heritage assets as well as design and
massing one of the reasons you picked up
there um cs20 requires extensions to
buildings to be subservient so that was
one of the reasons we refused if I could
just quote um
a bit of text from the appeal decision
so the inspector states that um it would
be more than double the building's
existing footprint and be somewhat
higher even so its position would be
centered to the pack House's southern
side and thus towards the center of the
cluster so that it would not be isolated
but viewed in conjunction with other
utilitarian structures furthermore its
location means that it would not
represent an incursion into the open
Countryside moreover given the typical
large scale of other closely situated
buildings and struct es the proposed
extension even though tall would not
overd dominate the cluster nor read as
an in congruent addition to the site and
then later on he dismisses the relevance
of cs20 because he considers that to be
more relevant to Housing Development um
so he says because it sits within an
agricultural context any dominating
effect of the proposed extension upon
the existing building would not raise
undue concerns in a design
sense question relates to condition
six um were the committee minded to
Grant you you have put a condition uh
and understand what you're trying to
achieve with it um I just want to test
and perhaps the legal officer can give
some assistance here the robustness of
the of the condition and you
know how uh the the likelihood of being
a the likelihood of being able to
enforce such a condition and and B um
you
know if the applicant came back and
looked for variation to drop condition
six um that would seem to be fundamental
to me that if if if we're if we're if
we're taking a policy view that this is
for this site alone condition six in
some form has to stay but my primary
concern is about is it a condition that
stands up to scrutiny uh that and I
think the question of whether there's a
Vari down the line is is for another
night but I think what I want to
understand is how how confident we are
about the enforceability and robustness
of that condition and could could the
legal officer give any guidance to the
committee were it minded to want to
strengthen the robustness of that
condition yeah I mean I think which is a
great condition from the start point
from officer's perspective I think in
terms of um enforceability obviously it
is to a degree going to have to rely on
reports from members of the public so to
speak um in that you know that may then
cause them to visit and monitor um the
pack house obviously as to how
enforcement will carry that out I can't
comment on um I appreciate that you know
but I I think like I say it would rely
okay on reports from members of the
public or or anyone do you have any
advice on strengthening the condition I
think it's something we could look at
where're members minded to um I mean we
could always seek Chairman's approval um
if we were to look at that if you might
bear with me I did have one further
question just returned to my small brain
um so concern has been raised about
traffic movements and the
inappropriateness of routing of vehicles
accessing the site currently um other
sites right at the other end of the
scale the Amazon site um has a traffic
routing strategy um could I get some
advice on um the appropriateness of some
form of traffic routing uh condition um
to ensure that access to the site
doesn't adversely
impact the two local
communities I know it's it's big but
it's not the scale of Amazon I I agree
but from
a just want some thoughts from officers
of course my current understanding is
that the r orbe it the may be ones which
they
practice from looking at the site
history I don't think there are any
routing conditions attached to any of
the permissions we' which we've granted
at the site a lot of them have been done
through agricultural notifications so we
wouldn't be able to attach such
condition anyway what I will say with
rooting conditions is that they are very
difficult to enforce hence at Reddit
Gateway we needed a work Steering group
to try and make sure we could make sure
it was enforcable and you know that was
a it it it wasn't it showed it wasn't
impossible but it was very difficult to
get to that point and I think in this
case given the scale of operation we're
talking about the fact that they can
already operate from the site without
any firm routing strategy and given that
County highways haven't requested a
condition for one and there would be
doubts over enforceability if we were to
attach such a condition my advice would
be that we shouldn't be looking to
condition a routing plan if members were
minded to Grant thank
you than uh councilor Fleming
next
um Darren kind of pinch me question it's
all it's all on on uh on condition six
now the subservience thing you can't
build a high Bay Warehouse where you're
going to store pallets to be lower than
a pack house so I accept that the the
fact that it's taller than the other
thing um because I've worked in storage
and distribution for years so I
understand that but the fact that we've
now got foreign trucks taking things to
that site before we've built this thing
and if you've got a bigger storage
facility I can't see how you're going to
have less traffic
and and and why double the size of the
place if you're not going to do more
business so so the bit for me I'm
struggling with the the fact that um and
I'm hoping that you can help me with
this is why or how can we uh come up
with a a planning reason not to do this
based on the fact that there's going to
be a bigger turnover and all the things
in your condition are going to be
stretched and
pressed I would just say that um we've
obviously had the transport statement
submitted with the application um
similar statement was submitted the
previous application that wasn't refused
on basis of Highways impact um highways
have raised no objection officers assess
the application on the basis of the
information in the transport statement
which says that hgv movements would be
decreased by way of the proposals
because the you know the it would all
happen on site so that's that's all I
can really say to that I'm afraid we
just have to assess it on the basis of
the information that's been provided
just listen to what I've heard I I
understand yeah
okay thanks thank you councelor Harvey
um question for officers um the question
of Wasing these solid materials etc etc
mentioned the word
chlorine um were the officers aware of
this
particular issue I would call it a
problem um that the there would be some
the allegation is there could be some
impact on quality of uh runoff water as
a result of uh this change of operation
um we we officers aware of that if it is
true is is there any planning weight
that that the committee could give to
that particular issue or is it something
which um is not not proven we haven't
the evidence and we would be unsafe to
to to give any any any weight to it I'd
like you know I appreciate some guidance
thank you yeah um this is not something
that's come up in the supporting
document documentation with the
application this is something that's
only been raised by Third parties the
environmental health officer has been
Consulting on application and hasn't
raised this as an issue um they've uh
requested conditions relating to um I
think L contamination and which is quite
a standard condition and uh noise uh
sort of restrictions but nothing's come
up in this regard so that will be my
comments on
that councelor passingham
next um we we take a presumption in
terms of sustainable development with
planning and is the fact that if these
crops weren't grown here they'd be grown
abroad and imported a a fact that would
mitigate would would um be contrary to
sustainable development can it be
taken as uh you know if we grow them
here the crops here that's more
sustainable than importing them is that
a planning Factor uh yeah it is to a
degree because we've got to consider
environmental social and economic
impacts of of development uh it's one of
the points which the applicant raises in
their um submission is that it will
reduce unnecessary CO2 emissions as a
result of not having to do that 50 mile
round trip that the agent was talking
about so it's certainly something we we
always have to weigh up those impacts in
any planning balance for an application
and and the fact that it's locally grown
produce and um we need to be um more
resilient in ter for you know for the
future in terms of food um
sustainability it surely that's that's
all part of the same thing isn't it so
so it's quite from that point of view
it's an excellent development really
isn't it U sorry that I can say that
later it certainly complies with the
principal policy as10 o which looks to
support agricultural development that
being one of the reasons subject to
there being a need for it so that's
certainly why we haven't identified any
conflicts in terms of
principle uh more hands going up I
believe CLE pton was next and
then so I've just had the opportunity to
to review the most recent uh update from
the LF
lfi uh and they're talking about some
sensitivity sensitivity testing being
done um just from a process point of
view the recommendation is to Grant
permission um um subject to there being
no objection from the LFA LF llfa um but
that I'm assuming that uh the intention
would be that the sensitivity it is it
will be a requirement that the
sensitivity testing is undertaken and
then the question is the process if that
sensitivity
testing through a P show stopper uh
what's what's the process um because
we'll have resolved the Grant Subject to
so does that then come back to us or
will would officers would if it was a
showstopper from that perspective how
would it how would it
work so if members resolved to Grant
tonight in line with the recommendation
we wouldn't be able to issue the
decision tomorrow we would have to wait
for that llfa no objection to come in so
absolutely there's a requirement to do
that sensitivity testing and all the
other aspects that have been requested
and in fact they've put some information
in and that's gone off to the LFA
already to assess and consider the
reason why we've brought it with that
recommendation is that our understanding
is that it is a resolvable issue um if
it wasn't we would have been
recommending refusal but say for example
we get a month down the line and it
looks like there's no way to resolve
that objection we would be looking to
recommend refusal on drainage and
flooding grounds I believe we would be
able to delegate that
decision because the committee trigger
would have gone because we've got the
objection from the parish and Ward we
would then be looking to refuse and it
wouldn't have to come back to committee
um so that hopefully clarifies that we
can't do anything in terms of issuing
anything until we've got a no issuing a
grant I should say until we've got no
objection from the
nlfa councelor Harvey can I go back to
condition
six um the two words causing me some
concern um the words are arising
from
um is that do I interpret that to mean
that this is agricultural produce
produced at Old pasture
Farm because as it
stands I might think that arising from
means that I it doesn't matter how it
gets there or where it comes from it's
still arising from the activities on the
farm if that if that's the intention you
get one result on the other hand if the
intention is that this should mean that
it does mean uh not arising from but
produced
on Old pastes Farm it's a much more
restrictive condition um so which way am
I if it if it's meant to say um produce
produced on the farm why doesn't it say
that and if it doesn't say that and it
says arising from am I correct in my
assumption that it's really is a
condition that couldn't be enforced as
far as locality of
produce what I will say is that that
condition wording is not final so it's
to give members a flavor of what we want
to do I think it would be fair to
replace arising from with produced on
because that is the UN that that is the
intention of the condition what I would
probably suggest is I think as as um Amy
referred to previously if MERS are
minded to Grant I would suggest that we
go with the recommendation but agree
that the chair has site of the final
wording of that condition and in advance
of officers finalizing it and sending it
through to the chairman we agree it with
our enforcement team so we can go to
them and say this is our wording do you
think that's as good as it can do this
is the intention I.E we want to restrict
it to agricultural produce produced on
Old pastures Farm as you've said there
and I think that that's certainly
something that that we could Endeavor to
do if members are minded to to go that
way very good um I have one point of
clarification I was going to ask about
um a notice from the planning history in
the report that there are a number of
agnot um applications that were approved
between 2010 and 2014 for extensions to
Coal storage building um am I right in
understanding that that's the same
building
and if so is there a a question of
accumulative development that and has if
that is the case has that been
considered by officers and the inspector
when they saw the uh saw the
case yes so I can confirm that the the
four agnot um 2008 2010 2012 2014 all
Rel related to this building the
application building um it was extended
over
time
[Music]
um sorry what was the second part of the
question uh essentially has has that
planning history been considered against
our our core strategy in terms of our
policy and was that part of the
consideration by the inspector when they
considered the previous um application
the inspector would have had sight of
the planning history for the site
[Music]
um the other thing I would add is that
the inspector did a site visit so he
would have seen those buildings in situ
and still considered the impact in terms
of overdevelopment to not be the case
loveely thank you very much do we have
any further points
of uh clarification I think we've been
fairly exhaustive which is a good thing
so in which case we can move on to the
debate who would like to
start looking at each other across the
tables councelor Eden
look
straight okay
okay
um I would say that with the uh ability
for the llfa to be able to cancel this
out I'm I don't have a concern around
the flooding being an
issue uh to me or to my mind at least
the centralization idea
around um the app uh the agent's um
presentation makes logical sense and to
my logical mind um that reduction in
traffic flow or traffic movements makes
sense to me as well as another
positive um
argument um given the history uh and the
inspector's um report as well I'm not
sure that we've necessarily got a strong
material reason to actually go against
what the officers are recommending on
this one
uh so I mean we start I might as well
propose that we go along the line of um
the officer's recommendation to Grant um
with that delegated um wording on
condition
six thank you very much councelor pton
next thank you chair um I think we've
given this
application a strong and detailed airing
I think that we recognize that the
the residents have legitimate concerns
about
industrialization and
about what seems to be the new scale of
the
business against that um and I think
those those questions have have been
explored and the position from a policy
perspective and that's where we have to
be gued for our decision- making has
been tested to
destruction um with that in mind um I
will second second the recommendation to
Grant planning permission subject to the
question of the uh the wording for
condition six to be uh Revisited uh in
conjunction with you chair um with the I
think the message very very clearly is
to strengthen uh the condition so that
we are talking about uh what arises out
of uh pack House Farm
um um I'd also uh with a mind to this
question of contamination and I know
there's a sensitivity study I'm not
entirely sure what contaminated Land
watching brief means but I think
something along something that gives us
some something to uh ensure that the
applicant manages land contamination
appropriately I think I if if the
proposer is uh willing to uh allow for
officers to to explore that with the
chair because I think there is some
concern around the impact on the broader
Network it may be that the llfa
themselves come up with something uh
then the sensitivity C may say it's okay
as long as you do x y and Zed and I
think if the committee can be assured
that XY and Zed find its way into an
ultimate decision notice or that there
is some mechanism for uh looking at
contamination then I would be
comfortable with uh and if the uh if
councelor Eden's prepared to to to go
with that I'll support that to
Grant yeah that will sounds very
reasonable thank you very much um who
would anyone else like to contribute
councilor Keithley yeah thank you chair
um I think councilors Eden and pton have
um put a decent case I I can see why
residents are worried about this
potential industrialization here it
seems like a very big extension to the
existing building but we've got to be
minded that there is already an appeal
decision in respect of the impact of
this development on the character um so
I think that is extremely important the
um the the sustainability argument I
think is something we've got to also
consider that the applicants putting
forward a case to reduce Road mileage to
to stop having to travel some
significant difference at distance to to
to pack its products and there will be
some environmental benefit as a as a
result of that um we've heard that the
the flooding issue is is is sort of held
back actually we're waiting to to get a
response from that and and the planning
officer said that that that issue is
resolvable um I would also know we've
heard a lot about flooding in recent
recent days in that area and all the way
down the Haven actually and and that's
already happening regardless of whether
or not this shed is there I'm not so
sure putting the shed up on the hard
standing that's there already is going
to make that big accumulative difference
to what we're already seeing in that
area um I think the key thing is is to
satisfy the
um local residents that we're not going
to see an industri Ral sized
scale um business growing like Topsy
bringing stuff in from all over the
continent to pack there is this key of
uh conditioning the um the location of
the products so if these are products
that are grown and arise well not arise
but are produced from this farm and
they're being packed on that site then I
think we should be satisfied that um our
planning enforcement team can can
actually control that if it's brought to
our attention that stuff is coming in
from outside so for all those Reasons
I'm minded to um go with the officer's
recommendation thank you very much
anyone else Council passingham I I would
agree with the previous speakers that in
terms of sustainable development it's an
excellent development it it's um a rural
uh developing the rural economy it's uh
productivity gain in that there's not
these wasted Journeys it's a a reduction
in carbon emissions there's more uh food
security locally by producing locally
rather than importing so uh and as
there's the the um the officers have
provided all the information then that
that all the other conditions will be
met I I think I'll be voting
favor thank you very much councilor
Fleming
uh just a quick one really um my only
concern is potentially coming back to
see if they can water down uh condition
number six I think we have to make that
watertight and absolutely nailed on and
uh as long as we can do that then I
think I'll support the
others really good thank you um for my
part I I do agree and I think condition
six is um fundamental to this
application being acceptable um along
with the lfa's uh contribution being and
no objection um I I certainly do see
where the local objection has come from
on this and I think we we do recognize
that from a polic policy standpoint
particularly in light of the appeal
decision we have to be very mindful of
what we can get away with from that um I
also think that it's worth noting that
through granting permission we actually
exercise control as a local planning
Authority in applying these conditions
and
I'm very sure that if any um
a concerns were uh to arise regarding
outside um traffic going into the site
from other Farms that we would find out
about it very quickly uh so on that
basis I'm I'm happy to support and
obviously lend my uh voice as chairman
to um the strengthening of um condition
six yeah and Alice wants to clarify a
point Thank You chairman um so if I
could just clarify so I think the The
Proposal is very clear this is just
before members vote I wanted to clarify
Council peneton the point you made
contaminated land just to make sure I'm
understanding exactly what you're
requiring us or requesting that we do um
so obviously I think we were talking
about the contamination contaminated
Land Land watching brief which is
separate to what the llfa have asked for
so what is it if if you don't mind just
explaining what exactly you um require
us to do I I think that um there is
there is
concern uh that not only is the the
potential that the network if you will
um um you know that is over is
overwhelmed but also with this question
of the use of chemicals uh in the
processing that there is a a robust
system in place to ensure that there's
there's no leakage into the to the water
Network or that is minimized so that the
land and the water courses are not
contaminated by virtue of the operation
uh I think it does it it's a longside
but you know it may be that the
sensitivity study touches on that but if
it doesn't I think this question of the
potential for contamination the use of
chlorine getting into the water system I
think we just need to make sure that
we've got the that the applicant has in
place robust and demonstrable processes
to ensure that doesn't
happen sorry just through you chairman
um so just to clarify we would obviously
attach any conditions that the llfa
provide um just conscious if they don't
require any conditions relating to this
specific
point I just would like some guidance as
to how members would like us to deal
with that obviously we can attach a note
to any forthcoming decision notice I
don't think we've got with without a
request from environmental health or the
llfa I don't think we've got a policy
hook to be able to kind of draft our own
condition so it it's if you could just
give me a bit of a steer on that so we
know kind of how to I think if if we
find ourselves without a policy hook
then a notice as far as we can go uh but
it also Flags to our environmental
colleagues um to to look out for this
and it was something that the committee
had some concern over um so uh happy to
be uh for you to leaz with the chair as
appropriate off the back of the llfa
work uh and and make the make the the
updates as as you and the chair feel
appropriate thank you for that
clarification charie good I think
everyone's spoken who want want to um in
which case we have a proposal to Grant
in line with the officer's
recommendation with wording of
conditions six and8 to be agreed with
myself can I see all those in FA subject
to the and of course subject to the LFA
um as as per the officer
recommendations can I see all those in
favor
please that's unanimous check thank you
very much in which case committee
resolves to Grant application 23/ 01799
slfl okay um just the last item then
item six urgent business there's no
urgent business thank you very much in
which case uh meeting is
closed